[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le camp de ceux qui boycottent Thomas ne
cache pas sa déception je pensais qu'on
serait plus nombreux à être dans cette
dynamique de se dire on veut montrer un
signe fort un footbusiness qui ça fait
aucun sens cette histoire du Qatar plus
ça va avancer plus ça va être entre
guillemets une vraie fierté aussi pour
le prochain match des Bleus Thomas sera
en forêt sans écran pour résister à la
tentation alors cette technique
sournoise pour boycoter le Qatar est
rendu possible grâce à une télécommande
capable d'éteindre n'importe quel télé
jusqu'à 45 mètres de distance technique
complètement assumée par ces militants
qu'il a fabriquent et la vente même sur
Internet 20 euros car si elle peut être
très agaçante c'est une technique avant
tout pacifiste Marc vos enfants ne
mettent plus le nez dehors à cause des
grandes chaleurs
optez pour le baby-foot
Qatar édition le baby-foot Qatar édition
est le premier baby-foot avec
climatisation intégrée à l'insupporter
français fait découvrir son logement la
petite salle de bain que je trouvais est
grande c'est très bien et c'est très
propre c'est nettoyé aussi tous les
trois jours pour certains tout semble
correct mais un peu plus loin sur le fan
village encore
des trains tout d'un coup la caméra
n'est plus la bienvenue votre travail
est de montrer les choses positives ou
les choses négatives cet homme a en
chemise grise se dit être un responsable
du site il demande à ce que les images
du tournage soient supprimées et oui
grâce à la Coupe du Monde au Qatar les
Chinois ont découvert que le monde
entier avait abandonné le masque alors
l'équipe de foot chinoise ne participe
pas à la compétition mais elle est tout
de même retransmise en direct sur la
chaîne d'État chinoises une chaîne où on
n'a pas vraiment l'habitude de voir ces
images en Chine nouvelle offensive du
covid-19 et nouvelle mesure drastique
pour tenter d'endiguer l'épidémie 6
millions de personnes sont confinées
depuis hier à zinczu dans l'est du pays
c'est là qui a implanté une gigantesque
usine d'iPhone nous vous en avons parlé
hier
usine ou les ouvriers ont manifesté en
début de semaine en raison des mesures
sanitaires mises en place mais aussi à
cause de retard de salaire ce Chinois
confiné s'emporte à la télé anglaise la
Coupe du Monde embarrasse beaucoup le
gouvernement chinois parce que tous les
gens confinés regardent la télé et ils
n'ont pas de masque pourquoi
différents en Chine que dans le reste du
monde il devrait y avoir une raison
valable à ça mais il n'y a aucune
explication il nous force à rester à la
maison
allez on perd pas le rythme
et on passe au suivant
et derrière les Bleus j'imagine bien sûr
évidemment comme tous les Français
d'accord et vous allez regarder le match
pas du tout je ne suis pas fou du tout
je
vous ai pas fait derrière
je vais sûrement le savoir
Guy Roux qui a
j'ai oublié
il est 14h ce lundi quand un homme
surgit dans une classe de première d'un
lycée du centre-ville de Nantes quelques
minutes seulement après la sonnerie il
est cagoulé habillé en noir et se dirige
immédiatement vers un élève assis au
premier rang il lui enfile un sac sur la
tête avant de le traîner de force en
dehors de la salle de classe sous les
regards médusés de ses camarades et de
son professeur personne n'a eu le temps
de réagir à avoir emprunté une 4L en bas
de chez vous ce qui vous a valu quand
même d'être pris en photo de face et de
profil au commissariat c'est votre
période jeune racaille ça c'est vous qui
l'avez légendé
la rendre la voiture
au centre-ville pour aller boire des
coups et puis en fait quand je suis
remonté dans la voiture je me suis fait
serrer voilà la direction du lycée
prévient la police et cherche à joindre
les parents de l'adolescent des
professeurs et surveillants fouillent le
lycée de fontenomble pour tenter de
retrouver l'adolescent en vain tous sont
persuadés que le lycéen est en danger
jusqu'à ce que l'élève se présente de
lui-même au bureau de la vie scolaire un
peu penaud et dépassé par les
conséquences de sa disparition il
explique qu'il s'agissait d'une blague
pour son anniversaire les policiers
n'ont visiblement pas le même sens de
l'humour puisque l'adolescent a été
conduit au commissariat pour être
interrogé la beauté de ce désert du
Kazakhstan
c'est là que Yann rouge a décidé de
poser une slackline de 500 mètres
sous une température de 50 degrés et
face au vent le funambule estonien
s'accroche au fil de ses rêves et ça
c'est pas rien
regarde là-bas regarde c'est sale voilà
voilà ce qu'on trouve voilà
régulièrement sur les bords de route
partout là regardez c'est pas du jus
d'orange
toutes ces bouteilles ce sont des
bouteilles ou les chauffeurs routiers
urinent dedans et puis les balances
regardez vous en avez d'autres ici il y
en a partout
et je préfère pas savoir ce qu'il y a
dans les sacs poubelles qui sont fermés
après avoir créé la surprise sur le
terrain ils sont fidèles à leurs
habitudes en tribune et dans le
vestiaire à leur départ c'est nickel la
petite touche origami en bonus
en japonais on dit comment super bon
vous allez voir les Japonais
[Rires]
[Musique]